Ann: The importance of ...
of the two factors of scale
and of gesture in
abstract expressionism are
exemplified in the
paintings of Franz Kline.
Usually with a white background
and then either only with black
or with black and some other dark colors
in a very sober, somber
but very strong key,
we have canvases that
present I think perhaps
a very American idea in
terms of the expaniveness
of the landscape in terms
of the bravado of the new.
It's easy to make generalizations about
how serene American art differs
from European art, but
in the case of these
paintings by Franz Kline,
I think it's actually,
it holds true.
The abstract expressionists saw
what they felt were the elegant qualities
of European art as something that needed
to be replaced with
painting that focused on
a sort of rawness or brutality even
that seemed to exemplify the new world.
Scale was one way. They
were making paintings,
not that you could paint on an easel,
but that need to be painted on the floor
or just have the canvas tacked
on the wall of the studio
because these were
paintings that were bigger
than the human arm span or height
and instead these were paintings
whose scale was going to engulf you.
They were not paintings
that you were going to
dominate, either as a maker or a viewer
and similarly, you are not going to have
a polite brushstroke daintily made by
holding a brush in one hand and a palette
in the other hand, but instead the kind of
forceful, gestural strength
that means that stroke
was made not just with
fingers, not just with a wrist,
not just with an elbow
but with the whole arm
and probably even the whole body
and when you look at those marks
on a Franz Kline painting,
you have the feeling almost
of bridges in America
or railroad tracks or these
other parts of the country
that were typical of the
technologies and the industry
that had set America
apart in the 19th century.
Franz Kline was one of the
regulars at the Cedar Tavern
and really a [unintelligible]
member of the
abstract expressionist group.
I think we hear a lot of stories about how
solitary they were in their struggles
or how moody they were
as they wrestled with their art,
but in fact that wasn't always the case.
There was often times real camaraderie,
real helping of each
other at difficult stages
and Franz Kline was one of those
who was the most supportive
and really inspiring to the
painters and sculptors around him.